[Music]
the next time you're admiring a plant
consider that you and every other animal
are meant to admire a flowers color
shape and smell flowering plants may
have arrived late in the Earth's history
but they evolved fast and they displaced
many other kinds of plants we have to
think of flowers it's very delicate
plants and that's not exactly wrong but
they are also world class competitors
who took over the planet what is the
secret of flower power Charles Darwin
was also confounded by this question in
1879 Darwin read an essay by another
scientist John Ball and that essay was
titled on the origin of the flora of the
European Alps the essay was given at a
meeting of the Royal Geographical
Society in June of 1879 in balls essay
he notes that the fossil evidence of
flowers appears very rapidly he then
goes on to wonder how the flowers
appeared so rapidly and diversely
if evolution by natural selection were
really responsible for their appearance
in other words according to Bell and the
fossil record flowers appeared in the
Late Cretaceous about 145 million years
ago and then there were so many
different types seemingly all of a
sudden John Ball questioned how natural
selection could account for flowers
sudden appearance where did their
ancestors come from and how could
natural selection operating on a long
time scale by Darwin's definition
provide so many different kinds of
flowers so quickly so later that same
year 1879 Darwin wrote a letter to his
friend and fellow scientist Joseph
Hooker in it Darwin writes the following
sentence the rapid development as far as
we can judge of all the higher plants
within recent geological times is an
abominable mystery the phrase abominable
mystery becomes one of the most oft
quoted Darwin phrases of all time and
probably one of the most popular quotes
about flower evolution in
general what Darwin meant was that ball
really had him on this one he didn't
know how natural selection could explain
the rapid evolution of flowering plants
it went against one of Darwin's central
posits about evolution via selection
he said natural and non facets altom or
nature never makes leaps consider this
the first flower from the fossil record
appeared 125 million years ago this was
our calf rictus which means old flower
this plant is extinct now but there it
appeared in the fossil record the flower
may be indiscernible because it's small
and inconspicuous but it is present and
that's what makes this plant unique it's
a short shrubby plant with small flowers
but the flowers are there then a mere 40
million years later there's flowers
everywhere this is a relatively short
evolutionary time consider that the
first land plants arose about 420
million years ago in the Silurian and it
took another two hundred and ninety
three million years to get to the first
flower and then 40 million years later
there are flowers everywhere even more
puzzling flowering plants are the
dominant form of planet of plants on the
planet depending how you count they're
anywhere from three hundred thirty
thousand to four hundred thousand
species of flowering plants you can see
why this would be a dilemma also at the
time there was nothing that looked even
remotely like an intermediate there were
cones from the conifers and there were
flowers cones don't look too much like
flowers so how did flowers arise in 1879
though the fossil record wasn't nearly
as clear as it is now we have a much
better understanding where flowers came
from and how that evolution could have
happened much quicker than Darwin
suspected we now know about more
mechanisms for the creation of new
species than were known during Darwin's
time for example we now understand
polyploidy which is
where the chromosomes can double or
triple during reproduction and we also
have a much better picture of the fossil
record in fact in a paper from 2013
Peter a Hochuli and Susanne Feist
Burkhardt found pollen from an extent
flowering plant called afro polis in
northern Switzerland that they estimate
to be between 252 and 247 million years
ago or even earlier that would be 100
million years earlier than the date
Darwin found so abominable they also
suggest that the pollen is of a type
that is usually insect pollinated most
likely from beetles given the beetles
were also present during this time such
a plant could have been like present-day
gymnosperms that extra 100 million years
certainly helps Darwin out a bit still
pollen isn't a flower it could be that
flowers just don't fossilize very well
which they don't some botanists have
suggested we're just not looking in the
right place it may also be that early
flowers were just small the conifers and
cycads of the Jurassic were so dominant
that flowers were just waiting in the
understory so to speak this scenario was
true of early mammals which were also
small but got bigger after the demise of
the dinosaurs
additionally the flowers may not have
been woody and again this would have
limited their ability to form fossils
interestingly molecular evidence puts
the advent of the flowering plants back
to about 290 million years ago way
before the Cretaceous
how would molecular evidence even work
in trying to determine the age when
something from that long ago evolved the
main molecular technique used is that of
the molecular clock this basically looks
at DNA within an organism that would
change on a regular basis that is an
organism that has a background rate of
mutation that wouldn't be associated
with reproduction or natural selection
generally with plants botanists are
looking at similar
these are differences within a
particular piece of chloroplast DNA this
technique assumes that the DNA within
the chloroplast changes at a regular
rate and that the more different it is
from current DNA the longer ago it must
have come on the scene why the fossil
record and the molecular evidence don't
match up probably has to do with those
ideas we mentioned about early flowering
plants not being the best at forming
fossils whatever the exact origin of the
flowers we do have some good evidence of
what her very early flowers may have
looked like and how they might have
evolved from conifers botanist also tend
to agree that the flowers form a good
group also called a monophyletic group
that is a group with one descendant and
all of the offspring yet other botanists
suggest that the flower may have evolved
more than once
still conifers and ferns and mosses have
been around much longer than flowering
plants so how were there so many
different species of flowering plants in
such a short time the answer may lie in
the fact that many flowering plants are
both pollinated and dispersed by animals
an animal moving pollen between plants
could become more specialized then get
pollen from only one type of plant now
the plants pollinated by that animal are
reproductively isolated from other
plants this is the key to speciation or
the formation of new species the other
way animals can be key in speciation is
through dispersal if an animal disperses
the seed to a new environment it can be
in a new island figuratively speaking
that is the animal has dispersed the
seed to a new location where it can no
longer breed with its old population so
it becomes reproductively isolated and
speciation occurs now it would be a good
time to remind ourselves about the
taxonomy that botanists used to describe
groupings of plants do you remember our
mnemonic device King Phillip K
came over from good Spain King stands
for Kingdom the easiest we're only doing
one kingdom in the whole course and
that's plants Phillip stands for phyla
we've discussed a fuse phyla we started
with mosses the bryophyte ax we talked
about ferns to ridda Fida and then we
learned all about pine a fighter the
largest phylum of the conifers class is
the next grouping of different orders
there are essentially two classes of
flowering plants the next level down the
order is helpful in thinking about
evolutionary relations of plants like
class it's named for the type family
that best represents the order there are
dozens of orders and so one example is
the lay me a Lee's all orders and then
the suffix a Lee's so there's a sort of
rule for you in botany it's named after
the family lamiaceae II which is the
mint family but it also includes about
20 other families like the verbum ASA II
which include the verbena herbs and the
OL EAC or the olive family the family
level in botany such as the lamiaceae II
that we just met always and in the
suffix SAE the largest plant families in
terms of numbers of species are the
orchid AC II the orchids the asters
which are the sunflowers and the
fabaceae E or the peas and then the last
two groupings are genus and species a
genus is a particular grouping within
the plant family and the species name is
actually comprised of both the genus and
the specific epithet in a sense this is
like having a last name and a first name
only what we think of as a last name
comes first and this is akin to the
Chinese way of naming so for example
when we discussed Pinus ponderosa the
pinus part is the pine genus and the
specific epithet Ponderosa describes
which pine we're talking about the
ponderous or heavy one together the
genus and the specific epithet make up
the scientific name and we call this a
Latin binomial because
flatten and a scientific name it should
always be written in a certain way with
the genus capitalized than the specific
epithet lowercase and the whole thing
should be italicized or underlined in
fact this is the way we would write our
own scientific name Homo sapiens the
binomial system of biological
nomenclature was developed by a Swedish
botanist Carl Linnaeus but it's also
used for animals protists and fungus -
bacteria and viruses are harder to
classify - the species level because
it's difficult to know where one species
stops and another species begins
but generally field botanist those
interested in identifying plants in the
field focus on the family level and
families are named after the type genus
within that family which is the genus
that typifies the traits of the family
for example the genus pinus is the type
genus for which the family is named
another example would be the sunflower
family the type genus of sunflowers is
aster so the family name is Asteraceae
II there are about 600 families of
plants and some of that number depends
on the different ways molecular evidence
might be used to define some of the
families some botanists might lump two
families together where another will
split them the grouping of living things
like this is called taxonomy Carl
Linnaeus lived in the 1700s so he
predated Darwin now Linnaeus was a
Swedish doctor and at this time in the
mid 1700s all doctors were gardeners and
botanist since most medicines were
derived from plants or fungus Linnaeus
organized living things into a system
that is still the basis of the system we
use today all of his arrangements of
plants were based on reproductive
structures using evolutionary relations
within such groupings is called
systematics so there's a slight
difference between these two taxonomy
simply says knife fork spoon spork
chopsticks systematic says which came
first
as the simplest and as a necessity to
hunt then fork chopsticks clearly didn't
evolve from fork so that must be a
separate group I hope you can appreciate
the difference botanist don't really do
simple taxonomy without evolutionary
relations but knowing a few families
even if you can't remember the
evolutionary difference between them
helps a lot when trying to identify
plants in the field as each new
scientific advance came along the
sequence of these groupings were changed
a bit but none changed the thinking
nearly as much as molecular evidence as
with many things in botany molecular
evidence has changed the way we once
thought about the evolutionary
progression of flowering plants now as I
mentioned botanist focus on the family
it used to be thought that the earliest
flowering plants were those like in the
Magnolia family big showy flowers and
you can almost imagine the center part
of the flower looking a bit like a cone
and but the next came a hypothesis that
the earliest fossil flowers were quite
small and looked more like those in the
piper family or the piper AC II once
again molecular evidence provides a bit
of an alternative in 2013 the entire
genome of a small weedy shrub native to
New Caledonia had been sequenced
interestingly Darwin actually suspected
that the center of flowering plant
evolution had been a distant place that
science had not yet discovered and New
Caledonia is an island in the South
Pacific for the decade before this full
genome sequence was completed botanists
had used a variety of molecular
techniques to determine that this shrub
Amborella Trico pota
was the oldest extant flowering plant
this shrub is the only member of the
Amborella AC II and probably had other
relatives that were alive sometime in
the past it turns out that this shrub is
the sister group to all of the flowering
plants indicating that indeed it is a
common ancestor to all flowering plants
shrug gives us some clues about what the
earliest flowering plants might have
looked like because it's a shrub
botanist can confirm the hypothesis that
the earliest flowering plants were woody
however due to its weedy growth in the
understory likely the first flowering
plants were not towering trees like many
of the gymnosperms this plant is
dioecious which is another clue about
the early flowering plants how might a
flower even a rudimentary flower have
developed there are several models for
how this might have occurred the best
genetic techniques indicate that the
same genes that are responsible for
flower development in Amborella
are the same genes that are responsible
for the formation of the male cones of
the gymnosperms so it seems the flower
developed from the male cone before we
talk about the diversity of flowering
plants and there are anywhere between
300,000 and 400,000 of them depending on
how you count
we should assure ourselves that we
understand all the different parts of a
flower there are very few rules in
botany
but here's one I challenge you to check
for yourself all the flowering plants
have an outer ring of male parts with an
inner ring of female parts in botany
when something forms a ring we call it a
floral so the male parts of the flower
Horrell around the female parts in all
flowers that is the case for all flowers
supports the idea that the flower only
arose once in evolutionary history okay
so what are those male and female parts
of the flower male parts are called
stamens and that's pretty easy to
remember because they are men stamen
have an anther with a pollen and a stalk
called the filament the female part our
parts are a bit more complicated there
is a top part called the stigma I like
to say the sticky stigma because this is
where the pollen will land the stigma
then becomes this style I like to say
the style and style because it's usually
long and thin
and connects to the ovary at the base
the ovary is where the Ovilus housed and
collectively the female part is called
the carpel or the pistol at a minimum
flowers have either male or female parts
the typical flower has both male and
female parts and they're called perfect
flowers but some flowers can be all male
called staminate flowers and others can
be all female called pistillate or
carpet flowers the petals and sepals are
the perianth and this part is optional
some flowers have them and other flowers
don't but flowers such as black pepper
piper nigrum do not have the period
and flowers don't have to have sepals
which are the typically green leaves
under the petals sometimes the petals
and sepals can't be distinguished so
they're called Teeples the flowers of
magnolia trees have tea poles for
example the arrangement and the number
of stamens and carpels petals and sepals
varies with various families and this
was the distinguishing factor that
Linnaeus used to categorize his families
of plants
Linnaeus famously described stamens and
carpels in terms of brides and grooms so
in describing a flower that had five
stamens and one carpel he would describe
it as one bride in the bedchamber with
five groomsmen he did so to appear
modest but there was quite a bit of
outrage about this seemingly perverse
nature flowering plants are called the
antha fighter or the angiosperms which
means closed vessel recall that
gymnosperm meant naked seed and so
angiosperm comes from the greek an Jian
vessel and refers to the seed so instead
of the cones which have open seeds these
plants will enclose the seed in an ovary
that then swells to become the fruits
the phylum of flowering plants that
Antho Fida is traditionally divided into
two classes going back to a taxonomy
published in the 17th century by
botanist john ray which he called dicots
and monocots however the term dicot
isn't used anymore because it doesn't
represent a true evolutionary group
instead of dicots botanist used the term
eudicots so why weren't these good
groups but first let's look at the
difference between these two classes
which are still used just with eudicot
instead of daikon and then look at why
the name dicot had to be changed a bit
as you were probably taught at some
point the term dicot refers to dye
cotyledon the cotyledon is the seed leaf
or the first leaf that emerges in the
developing plan in dicots there are two
cotyledons that emerged at the same time
and monocots there's only one seed leaf
the difference between these two groups
of plants can also be seen in several
different physical aspects of the
flowers the veins in the leaf and the
arrangement of the vascular tissue in
cross-section so let's begin with the
flowers monocots have flower parts in
groups of threes that means monocots can
have three six or even nine stamens and
three or six carpals monocots will also
have three petals and three sepals like
Trillium or six petals and six sepals
like most lilies die-cuts have flower
parts in fours or fives
notice how the sepals petals stamens and
carpals are all in multiples of four or
five what's funny about using botanical
keys is that usually after 8 or 10 the
number just becomes many or even
infinity and I like to joke that
botanists don't really like to count
past ten let's look at leaf venation
and this is just what it sounds like the
veins running through the leaf of xylem
and phloem and monocots the leaf veins
are parallel like the veins in a grass
blade because a grass is a monocot in
dicots the leaf veins are netted like a
feather or like a palm pretty much
anything but parallel the dicots have a
tissue arrangement that is reminiscent
of that which we saw in woody plants in
fact most trees are eudicots or belong
to one of the groups that was removed
from the dicots altogether these removed
groups are called the basal angiosperms
the eudicot vascular tissue arrangement
has rings around the outside of the stem
with phloem on the outside and xylem on
the inside just like the woody stem only
now there is no cork cambium and no bark
so the dicots can have secondary growth
which is outward growth and wood
development but they don't have to do
this
the monocots don't have secondary growth
at all so the monocots don't have true
wood the monocots have vascular tissue
arranged in what I fondly learn
as monkey faces essentially these
bundles are arranged throughout the
plant and they consist of two large
columns of xylem which look like eyes
and phloem cells which look like a
forehead this vascular bundle also has a
small space called the lacunae which
looks a little like a mouth I don't know
maybe it's not a great analogy but if
you squint you can just make it out
so why the new word eudicots they seem
like nice divisions but there are a
number of flowering plant families that
don't fit very nicely in either of these
two categories for example the water
lily family nymph AC have a stem
arrangement that looks like a monocot
they have six sepals and they have what
looks to be one cotyledon but they have
netted leaf venation the question then
becomes where to put this family as it
turns out there are a few maybe a dozen
or so families in this predicament and
so many botanists lump them together in
a group called the basal angiosperms the
term basal implies that they are at the
base of the phylogenetic tree of the
flowering plants this is not a very
large group as they make up less than 5%
of all of the flowering plants basal
angiosperms often show combinations of
the following traits numerous flattened
or laminar stamens with wide filaments
numerous people's which are
indistinguishable petals and sepals many
separate carpals and alternate spirally
arranged leaves thus the old dichotomy
used to include many of the basal
angiosperms once these plants were taken
out of the dicots the new name the new
name became eudicots or true dicots i
mean who knows what those basal
angiosperms are indeed they're not a
cohesive group but they fit better on
their own than they do in the monocots
or the old dicots one plant family in
this group that students usually
remember as a basal angiosperms is the
Magnolia family the magnolias see the
ending a say ee implies a family the
magnolias have always
been placed at the bottom of the
flowering plants probably because the
carpals in this group superficially
resemble cones while they're not cones
this group is still in the basal
angiosperms mainly due to the numerous
Teeples and many separate carpals which
can be seen in the cone like structure
of the carpals each one of those
divisions is a carpel that houses an
ovule and that is where the bright red
seeds of the magnolias are born so
thinking about the evolutionary tree of
the flowering plants it might go
something like this
our oldest fossil flower is ARCA Fructis
it was a simple shrubby plant but
clearly a flower fast forward about 127
million years and we have the species
Amborella tri capita this is the living
sister group to all the remaining
flowering plants from here the basal
angiosperms were likely next on the
scene and from a common ancestor to the
basal angiosperms the monocots and
eudicots appeared in terms of diversity
as we mentioned only about 5% of
flowering plants are basal angiosperms
the monocots comprise about 25% and all
the rest are eudicots as I mentioned
there are probably between 300,000 and
400,000 species of flowering plants but
botanist don't seem to have as many
words to describe the shapes of flowers
as the shapes of leaves when I think of
flower shapes I generally think of
symmetry flowers can be radially
symmetrical or bilaterally symmetrical
there are a few descriptors like tube
shaped and bell shaped flowers but other
terms would be reserved for specific
flowers and botanists don't use them
broadly I think this is because there
are so many other ways to just determine
the family to which a plant belongs by
looking at the flower most wildflower ID
books will use color others will use in
fluorescence types an inflorescence
describes how the flowers are arranged
on the stem there are quite a few
discreet
of inflorescences a single flower on a
stem is called the solitaire in
fluorescence and flowers that alternate
up the stem is called an inflorescence
that's called a regime if those letters
are tightly compressed on the tip of the
stem it's called a spike an
inflorescence that has numerous flowers
forming a sort of umbrella shape is
called an humble from the latin on Bella
meaning sunshade which also gives us the
word umbrella but the most deciding
factor in the determination of the
species is the number and arrangement of
the male and female parts for example
members of the hibiscus family the
malvaceae have the stamen forming a tube
around the pistol or coming off directly
from the pistol this is called a mono
Delphis stamen and it's a key giveaway
for this family of course most children
are taught that flowers are showy and
smell nice to attract pollinators
animals that will enable the plant to
exchange pollen
however there are other adaptations of
flowers that are not reproductive a 2006
review chapter in the book ecology and
evolution of flowers Sharon Straus and
Justin Whittle review a number of
published studies that show a
correlation between pink and purple
flowers and drought or heat stress
remember that flowers of the same
species can have different colored
flowers the same as humans can have
different hair colors anthocyanins are
pigments not only in the leaves but also
in the flowers where they cause flowers
to be any hue of red or pink
anthocyanins are also the most common
pigments and flowering plants perhaps
because red and pink are also associated
with stress so in the Straus and Whittle
review the plant that had pink or purple
flowers had greater levels of
anthocyanins these anthocyanins were
also in the leaf where they help the
plant cope with higher levels of heat or
drought so here's an example where
flower color isn't related necessarily
to a pollinator preference
to a physiologic response additionally
pollinators may prefer large flowers but
large flowers are energetically and
hydrologically expensive from the point
of view of the plant there's a trade-off
between attracting pollinators and
making flowers small enough that there's
enough energy to make a fruit for later
dispersal of the seed and that keeps the
flower size modest in most plants the
world's largest single flower is the
rafflesia arnold i from the rainforests
of Indonesia
what do you think you to cut or monocot
it has five Paragon lobes which are
essentially giant hardened petals
it's a eudicot the largest record of the
individual flower was measured at over
one meter across that's about three feet
four inches this single flower weighed
24 pounds how about that for a corsage
it's actually a parasitic plant with no
visible leaves roots or stem which may
be why it's able to shunt all of its
energy into its massive flower size
interesting the common name is corpse
flower because it smells like rotting
flesh and this is also the common name
of the plant with the largest in
fluorescence remember that the
inflorescence is a collection of
individual flowers on the stem now the
largest in fluorescence goes to another
corpse flower but this one is called
Amorphophallus titanum
or the titan arum this is the corpse
flower that botanic gardens will often
put on special display when it flowers
because it doesn't flower very often
this in fluorescence can grow to a
height of 3 meters or 10 feet the leaf
of this plant can grow 6 meters or 20
feet tall it generally takes about 7 to
10 years for the first flower to bloom
and then it may bloom more frequently
like every 2 or 3 years or it might not
no rules in botany but there are
patterns why am i both of these
super-sized flowers smell like carrion
the answer is to attract flies the titan
arum is a monocot and the rafflesia is a
eudicot but they both live in Sumatra so
something about Sumatran rain
has pollinators that are attracted to
the smell of rotting flesh these
pollinators turn out to be carrion
eating beetles and flesh flies both of
these animals seek out rotting meat and
these corpse flowers trick them into
thinking they found it but not before
the animals have done the plants bidding
and moved pollen from one plant to
another certainly these beetles and
flies must think corpse flowers an
abominable mystery so the next time you
are admiring a flower its color its
smell or its shape remember that you and
every other animal are meant to admire
it you're doing exactly what the plant
wants